REBECCA MOORE: Hello,
good afternoon,
and welcome to Maps for Good,
savings trees and saving lives
with petapixel-scale computing.
I just love saying
that word, petapixel.
How's I/O going for you guys?
Yes?
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
Well, in my opinion we've
saved the best for near last.
My name is Rebecca Moore.
I'm the engineering
manager on the GEO team.
I lead two projects,
Google Earth Outreach,
which is our program that
works with nonprofits
and indigenous communities
all over the world
to foster the use of
Google's mapping tools,
to make the world
a better place.
And then also,
several years ago I
started the Google
Earth Engine project,
which is what we're
going to focus on today.
Both of these were 20% projects
that are now thriving teams.
So go Google.
We're going to talk
about a couple of things.
First of all, what is Maps for
Good, How did it get started.
I want to introduce you guys
to not only Earth Engine,
but the whole field
of geoscience.
A lot of times when we
talk about Earth Engine,
we're talking to specialists
in so-called remote sensing.
I think a lot of you guys are
Android developers or whatever.
So there may be
some new concepts.
We'll crack open
Earth Engine, look
under the hood at how it
works, why it's so amazing.
We actually have experimental
APIs that we'll demonstrate.
Then we're going
to talk about some
of the really exciting projects
that our partners are doing
that are making the world
a better place using
Earth Engine.
And finally show you
how you can get started.
So how did I get started?
I'm not an activist.
I'm just a computer
science nerd.
But I live in this beautiful
place in the Santa Cruz
Mountains.
And one day back in 2005 in
the summer, I opened my mail
and I got this.
OK, what does it say?
Hm.
So I'm a map geek,
so I studied it.
Notice of intent to harvest
timber, non-industrial timber
management plan area.
The legend was not that helpful.
If you look at it, it
sort of says black lines
tell you what's going on.
Well, the whole
thing's black lines.
So there were a couple
thousand of my neighbors
and I that got this
notice in the mail.
And most people threw it out.
Because they couldn't
understand it.
But Google Earth had just
launched two months earlier.
And I had been playing
with Keyhole before that.
And I thought what if-- I wanted
to understand what this map was
saying, because I was
worried that my community was
threatened.
We have the largest remaining
stand of old growth redwood
trees in Santa Clara County.
It's a beautiful place.
So over one weekend, I
opened up Google Earth.
And I found the same place.
And I started bringing in
the elements of the plan
onto Google Earth.
Where the helicopters were
going to land and take off.
Where the logging
zone was going to be.
How close it was going
to be to schools,
day care center, nursery
schools, and so on.
Google Earth also, of course
you know, gives us 3D.
So we had just
acquired SketchUp,
and one of my
colleagues helped me
make a 3D model of a
helicopter on a bombing run
over the schools.
Anatomically correct
helicopter, actually.
Tree to scale.
But because, in fact,
the plan was proposing--
because the land
was so steep, they
couldn't get the
logs out by road.
So they were going
to be helicoptering
over the community
in perpetuity.
So this was actually
the same time
when Al Gore was going around
with an "Inconvenient Truth."
I had a much smaller
audience, but I
was being asked to
present this Google Earth
visualization and the animated
fly over to the newspapers,
to the politicians, to
members of my community,
to the Sierra Club.
Because no one could understand
that 400 page document and read
those grainy black
and white maps.
But they could understand
the data in Google Earth.
And eventually,
it took two years,
there were a lot of
battles back and forth.
But using Google
Earth, we not only
showed that the plan
was a bad idea for fire,
safety, water pollution,
endangered species, and so on,
but actually that
it was illegal.
We used Google Earth to prove
that the plan did not even
meet the requirements
for consideration.
And so we stopped the
logging using Google Earth.
Here's where you're
supposed to cheer.
Yay!
[APPLAUSE]
So that got a lot of
attention in the media.
And I started being contacted by
nonprofits all over the world.
Teach us what you did.
It was one of the earliest
grassroots environmental uses
of Google Earth.
And so long story short,
as my 20% project--
because at this point I was now
a Google engineer on the Google
Earth team, another story
there-- I said, hey,
can I be the liaison to
the environmental community
and help them understand
how to use our tools.
And with several
other Googlers, we
started what became
Google Earth Outreach.
We now have more than 5,000
nonprofits all over the world
that are using Maps
API, creating KML,
Street View visualization.
They're doing all kinds
of things using our tools
for conservation,
human rights, disaster
response, cultural preservation.
There are some amazingly
beautiful projects
that people are doing.
So there I was in
the Brazilian Amazon
in 2008, because an
Amazon chief had actually
come to Google the year
before and asked for our help
to teach his people how to
put themselves on the map.
Literally, because
this was his territory,
and it was under threat.
There were illegal invasions
of his land happening
that you can even see in
the satellite imagery.
And when he saw that
in Google Earth-- he
was the first member of his
tribe to go to university--
he said, this is the tool
that will raise awareness
with people around the world
of the threats my people face.
And he told his
tribe the time has
come to put down the bow and
arrow and pick up the laptop.
But while we were
there, we also met
with a Brazilian geoscientist.
And he said to us, Google Earth
and Google Maps are great.
But in fact, the earth
is changing dramatically.
This is deforestation
in the Amazon
over a couple of decades.
That pattern is very typical.
They were losing more than
a million acres a year
of Amazon rainforest to
often illegal deforestation.
This scientist had
the methodology
to analyze daily
satellite data coming in
and automatically detect
areas of suspicious change.
And alert law enforcement.
Because the law enforcement
on the ground is very skimpy.
But the problem was, it
was like terabytes of data.
It required weeks of
processing on his desktop.
By the time you would get
the results, it was too late.
So he said, Google, you
have Google Earth and Maps.
You let us look at the data.
How about if you let us
measure, monitor, do science.
And do alerting on changing
phenomena on the earth surface,
like deforestation.
Well, that was a
pretty cool challenge.
And so we decided to do that.
That was the inspiration
for Google Earth Engine.
That you can not only look
at the data, the imagery,
but you can analyze it.
And so we think of Earth
Engine as deriving information
from all of this data
that is around us,
but has not been
thoroughly mined
for useful information for
people and for the planet.
So for example, there
are a ton of satellites.
This is just NASA's
satellites that
are orbiting the planet--
as we're sitting here--
working very hard,
collecting lots of data.
And not just pictures of earth,
but scientific measurements
that could relate to weather,
heat, all kinds of things.
And one example sensor
is the Landsat satellite.
It's been orbiting--
that program
has been orbiting earth
for more than 40 years.
Every 16 days, it
completes a pass
and it starts all over again.
It's never had a
break in coverage.
There's more than
3.6 million images
of Landsat data in the archive.
And it's a treasure trove.
And that's just one example.
Now I said that it's not
just red, green, blue pixels.
It's not just RGB.
And I want to say a little
bit more about that.
Because here's where the
interesting geoscience
comes in.
So let's go back to
high school physics.
We know the
electromagnetic spectrum.
So there's the visible light to
human beings, red, green, blue.
And then beyond that, there's
infrared and other bands.
These satellites are
actually taking measurements
across all of those bands.
So for example, here
is a Landsat image,
right near Burning Man.
There's various things
going on in that scene.
It's kind of hard to figure out.
There's clouds,
there may be snow.
There may be grass.
It's hard to tell.
Very, very typical
satellite image.
That's what you can see with
the red, green, blue bands.
But if instead you use the red
and the near-infrared bands,
you can discriminate vegetation.
Growing vegetation.
And that shows up here
in the dark green.
Or if you're interested
in snow-- snow and ice--
you can look at the green
and the mid-infrared band.
And that does an excellent
job of discriminating
snow and ice versus
everything else.
So this kind of data is
important for us to store.
So we became
committed to storing
all of this scientific-- these
spectral bands of information.
So there's the
nature of the data,
and then there's
the scale of it.
So I mentioned Landsat
is a huge archive.
It comes off the
satellites, and it
goes onto tapes in a
vault in South Dakota.
It's very secure.
But the problem is it's
difficult to get access.
And until 2008, it
cost $600 a scene.
So scientists used to say,
we would do the science
on the data we could afford,
not the data we needed.
But in 2008, the US government
enlightened data policy,
made all of Landsat free.
Suddenly the historic
archive and the data
being collected every
day-- massive amounts--
is now available
suddenly for data mining.
How could you possibly
handle that on your desktop?
You can't.
This is where cloud
computing comes in.
So with Earth Engine
we decided to focus
on five or six of the
most important satellites
that scientists were
telling us would
be transformative in advancing
science, natural resource
monitoring, if we
could get that data out
of those dusty archives
and online and available
for analysis.
So that's what we did
with Earth Engine.
And when you look
at this data center,
there's really two
things about this
that are important
for Earth Engine.
First the storage.
We're now storing
petabytes of this satellite
and other environmental
data coming in every day.
And then the compute resources.
Massive compute that's
co-located with that storage.
So when you have all the data,
and you have this compute,
what can you do with it?
Well for example, most
scenes look like this.
This is, I think it's Borneo.
But when you-- if
Landsat collects
let's say 20, 24 images
a year, the clouds
may be over one
pixel in one image.
But clouds move around.
They won't be over that
pixel in another image.
If we have all the pixels,
we can select the best pixel
from a stack.
And we can composite a
complete cloud-free image.
Here's another place.
This is the Isle
of Mull in England.
And this is after we composited
and removed all of the clouds.
it's like magic.
South America used to look like
this in Google Earth and Maps
a year ago.
Not that great, to be honest.
But after we applied
this technique
to all of South America,
It looks like this now.
And in fact, last spring we
did it for the whole planet.
And we launched the first
15 meter global cloud-free
satellite based
map of the planet.
And that is what you see in
Google Earth and Google Maps
when you open them.
And that was created
by Earth Engine.
So that was one time period.
The dates of those images were
approximately-- the pixels
that we used to make that
cloud-free mosaic were
approximately 2012.
We went back a
little earlier if we
had to in really cloudy areas.
But then we did
the next project.
We said, well we
have all this-- we
have like more than
30 years of data.
What if we could create
essentially a cloud-free image
of the whole planet every year?
And then stitch those
together into a seamless,
online animation that
you can navigate.
So we built that.
It's called Timelapse.
We launched it last May.
And it's an HTML5 video
animation of the entire earth.
Whereas you fly in, instead
of in Google Earth and Maps,
where the world is static,
it's animating underneath you
from 1984 to 2012.
And these are some of the
phenomena you can see.
You can see glaciers retreating,
crop circles of irrigation
appearing in the
desert of Saudi Arabia.
These artificial islands
sprouting off of Dubai,
because the tourism agency
wanted more beachfront.
And deforestation in the Amazon.
But we're not limited to this.
You can go anywhere in
the world in Timelapse
and you can find
interesting things.
Here's Las Vegas.
What do you see?
Las Vegas was the
fastest growing city
in the US during this period.
What it's saying to me
is Las Vegas is growing,
but Lake Mead is shrinking.
And that's pretty obvious.
You can see that in
just a few seconds.
Time Magazine was really
excited about this.
Maybe because their
name is Time, who knows.
But we worked with them
actually as partners
to launch this on
their site as well.
And they did a whole
series of science
and environmental
reporting of the phenomena
that you could see,
really for the first time,
in Timelapse that help
you understand things
like urban expansion or
desertification or climate
change.
Now what I wanted to point
out is the kind of compute
that was involved.
So this was almost 30
years of satellite data.
We analyzed more than two
million Landsat scenes.
It was almost a petabyte
of data, 909 terabytes.
It took two million
hours of computation.
But we sharded it
over 66,000 computers,
and so we had the result
in a couple of days.
I think it would've taken
300 years or something, if we
had tried to do it
on a single computer,
if it never rebooted
in those 300 years.
Those are
visualization products.
But the heart of why we built
Earth Engine was for science.
This is Carlos Souza.
He was the scientist who
originally inspired us.
That was his system, called
SAD-- Sistema de Alerta de
Desmatamento-- for detecting
and alerting on deforestation.
He has now built-- really
our first power user,
our first launched application--
running on the Earth Engine
API in Backend-- to monitor
deforestation in the Amazon.
It's a very canvas
app that allows
you to change the temporal
range on the client.
And you see the patches-- those
red patches of deforestation--
that show up,
depending upon what
occurred during that time range.
Every month, he
publishes a bulletin
that goes to law enforcement--
to Brazilian law enforcement
authorities on what has been
seen using Earth Engine.
And he reported to
us that it's cutting
in half the time
it used to take.
And moreover, now he can give
it to all these other countries
in the Amazon Basin and around
the tropical forested belt
of the world who've
been wanting that.
But they didn't want to
deal with running a software
package from this researcher.
Now that it's online
in Earth Engine,
they can all have access to it.
Back in the US, we did a
project with Matt Hansen,
who's a leading scientist
in analyzing Landsat data.
And that was detecting
forest change
in Colorado in 2000 to 2010.
Finding things like pine bark
beetle damage, wildfire damage.
We then went global
with Matt Hansen
and created the world's first
high resolution global map
of deforestation, from 2000 to
2012 at 30 meter resolution.
You would think that people
would have known where forest
was and where it
was disappearing.
But in fact, there were
many, many countries
in which there was
complete ignorance.
So that's what it looks like.
It was published in
Science Magazine.
We've had thousands of
institutions now downloading
the data and doing different
kinds of analysis on,
well how does this
relate to national parks?
Are those parks
actually protecting
the landscape or not?
I should say about this,
this was a million hours
of CPU on 700,000
Landsat scenes.
We ran it on 10,000
computers in parallel.
So we had that in
less than a week.
That one would have
taken 15 years.
So the ideas were
like turbo-charging
this really great geoscience for
the benefit of the environment
and the benefit of all of us.
Here's an animation
that shows you
some of the data in the
data set that we produced.
This is the island of Sumatra.
You see the advancement
of deforestation,
including encroaching on
their supposed national parks.
And now the final
step with this project
is-- World Resources Institute
has used this data as the base
map for a monthly
alerting system,
called Global Forest Watch--
and go to globalforcewatch.org--
where anyone can find out what's
going on, in near real time,
in a forested place
on the planet.
You can subscribe to a place
you may be interested in.
Businesses are using this.
Governments, media, and so on.
So we're happy about that.
OK let's crack
open Earth Engine.
So This is sort of a typical
top down, bottom up thing.
At the bottom of Earth Engine
we have this massive public data
catalog that we're
updating every day.
And we keep adding to the
data sets that we host,
based upon demand from
our community of users.
On top of that, we have
two kinds of computation.
Either interactive on demand.
Or batch, when you
have a really big job,
like those one million
hours of computation
for the whole world.
We have restish APIs.
But in fact what our users
really are developing against
are our client libraries
in JavaScript and Python
that have about 600 functions
now that do image analysis
and do vector analysis, or
fused image and vector analysis.
And finally, on
top of that, Google
has built a couple
of apps and we've
got this growing community of
users that are building this.
We're still experimental.
But we have now a couple
thousand developers on our API.
So this is kind of going
through some of the data.
I've mentioned Landsat.
But there's MODIS,
there's elevation data.
You can do a lot of interesting
things when you know elevation.
Weather data we're
getting every three hours.
Fire data, and so on.
Another important point that's
kind of small on this slide.
If you have a Google
Maps Engine account,
and you're uploading your own
data-- raster data, or soon
your vector data-- you can
analyze that from Earth Engine.
Privately, securely.
So that's kind of good.
You get access to both public
data and your own private data
for analysis.
So what can you do
with Earth Engine?
Well, at the most basic,
you grab an image.
Your image or one of the
images from our catalog.
You can then apply
an algorithm to it.
This may be one of our
several hundred algorithms
we've provided, or our
scientific community has
contributed, or maybe one
that you've written yourself.
You can also filter a
collection of images
by date, or by
geography, by metadata.
And this is actually where it
gets much more interesting.
Because if you're just analyzing
one or two satellite images,
don't come to Earth Engine.
We're like the Large
Hadron Collider when
you need like a
little telescope,
or a little-- I don't
what the analogy would be.
But where it gets
interesting is when
you're trying to operate
over massive amounts of data.
So you apply the algorithm
to the whole collection.
And then you can reduce
it to a single image.
This is truly MapReduce.
And finally, you can do
aggregate statistics over that.
Yes, truly MapReduce.
Someone laughed, OK.
I mentioned-- I'm going to kind
of speed up a little bit here,
because I want to
get to the demos.
But there's on-demand.
You'll see lots of demos of
this interactive from our IDE
or through the API.
If you have a
really big job, you
can do a batch job, which
we run at lower priority.
So it's very efficient.
We parallelize-- all
of those functions
are intrinsically parallel.
So imagine there's some area
you're trying to analyze.
We split it up into
256 by 256 image tiles.
We distribute those to thousands
of computers if need be.
Each one performs its part of
the computation, the algorithm.
Under the covers of the API,
we stitch it all back together.
And there you go.
All right, some code.
Remember I told you
we were removing
massive amounts of
clouds and producing
that first global
cloud-free image?
You can do this too,
in four lines of code.
I hope this blows your mind.
So if we walk through this, and
we have JavaScript and Python.
The first thing accesses our--
you select an image collection.
This is requesting the
Landsat 7 satellite.
We're filtering it down in the
next line to a range of dates,
from January 1, 2011
to December 31, 2012.
The third line is where
the magic happens.
It says median image
is filtered dot median.
What we're doing there is for
every pixel in every band,
we're finding that median.
And the statistical
median tends to rule out
clouds, which are very bright,
or shadows, or data caps, which
are very dark.
And you end up getting a
very nice representative
version of that pixel.
So we're doing statistics on
the planet, which you can only
do when you have
massive amounts of data.
And then finally,
adding it to the map.
And the other thing
I should point out
is when you write this code,
you're creating an expression.
It's almost a Lisp-like.
It's a functional
expression of something
that will undergo
lazy evaluation.
We store that code.
It's applied when you
use our interactive IDE
to browse around.
And it runs it on
demand or in batch mode.
All right.
Demos.
So we have two frontends.
One is our Workspace
GUI that's really
well-designed for
classification.
This is our home page.
If you go to
EarthEngine.google.org,
you'll see a series of
interesting data products
that have been produced.
There's a data catalog
that you can browse.
But now what we're
going to do is
use Google's machine
learning infrastructure,
which we've wired in into
the backend of Earth Engine.
So you know YouTube did
a major machine learning
on the corpus of YouTube videos.
And they found that
there's a lot of cats.
Well, I'm really curious
to see what people
find in all the corpus
of satellite data.
So what we're doing here is
first choosing a range of dates
that we want to classify.
What we're going to try
to build is a classifier
of forest versus non-forest.
And literally you
can do it in a couple
of minutes in our Workspace.
We're creating the classes.
You could have two classes.
You could have 10 classes.
Of course, the more
classes you have,
it puts a burden on can
you really discriminate
those different classes from one
another, based upon the data.
Remember that we're not just
analyzing the three band RGB
data that we see here,
but underneath that are
multiple bands.
In the case of Landsat,
it may be 10 bands,
depending upon which sensor.
So now we're going to
train it, by putting down
here are representative spots
in this image that are forest.
You can do this by
dropping a placemark,
you can create a polygon.
And later, the machine
learning infrastructure
is going to try to extract
what's the pattern there,
as distinct from now
we're putting markers
down for non-forest.
Looking for those places that
are clearly not forested areas.
Google's machine
learning backend
has a whole series
of different methods
you can use-- cart,
random forests.
We're going to use the fast
Naive Bayes, because it's fast.
And it actually does
a pretty good job.
So what we're doing now
is we're training a model.
And you can see in the
upper left, and there we go.
And I did not speed this up.
This is actually
the way it works.
It's now built that model.
It's applied it to
what we're looking at.
And as we zoom
out or pan around,
here is that
just-in-time evaluation.
We're now applying
that model throughout
the Brazilian Amazon.
And Chief Almir now
has classification
of forest versus non-forest.
So that's the GUI.
Now let's look at the IDE.
You remember that
code on cloud removal.
So it's a simple
IDE, but we have
a series of examples for
vector and raster analysis
that are built-in to
help you get started.
There's a code
editor that has tips.
If you're missing
your semicolons,
we have built-in documentation.
When you hit run,
that's when you actually
cause your algorithms
to run over the area
that you're looking
at in the viewport.
And finally, this
is really important,
the Get link allows you to
say, OK, I really like this.
Give me a link.
I'm going to share
it with someone
else who is an Earth
Engine Trusted Tester.
They'll open it up.
And they'll see exactly
your analysis on the data.
And it will run for them.
It's a great way to collaborate.
So now we're actually going
to run a cloud removal.
The first thing I'm going
to show you is bad data.
So I think the first image
here is one week of Landsat 7.
There was a defect
in the satellite
that has these scan line gaps.
22% of the pixels are missing.
There's clouds.
But now we're going to bring
in that cloud removal code.
This is what you get for--
this is the South Bay.
And if you pan around, you
would see this elsewhere.
Here's another example.
In this case, we're going
into that area of Burning Man.
And we're going to show those
different types of information
you can extract from the same
fundamental set of imagery,
just looking at different bands.
That's the RGB imagery.
Now we're going to bring in
the vegetation analysis that
just looks very simple.
It's one line of
code in Earth Engine
to compute what you just saw.
And now we're running the
snow and ice detector.
Now, OK, that's interesting.
Who cares, right?
Well, one of our
science partners
is now using this to look
at snowpack over the Sierra.
And in fact has determined
very efficiently,
in just a few lines
of code, you can
see the snowpack that was in
the Sierra in May of 2010.
And then you can see the
snowpack as of last month.
Again, you see pulling
down the code window.
So that's 2010.
And now we'll turn off
2010 and turn on this year.
There's the drought.
You can see it
with your own eyes.
So all of those were
analyzing one point in time.
Imagery at one point in time.
Where it really
gets interesting,
since we have years, decades
of data, is looking at trends.
Doing change detection.
So this is a fun data set
we wanted to show you.
We start with-- it's called
City Lights at Night.
There's a particular
satellite that
is measuring light emission,
both visible and a bit
of near-infrared.
And you can see the major
cities in Europe, for example.
But we have in there I
think 20 years of data.
So we're wondering, how
are these cities growing
or shrinking?
So we have an algorithm that
lets you do a linear fit.
And then you can produce this.
Again, in just a
few lines of code,
and you can see Spain
is getting-- red means
it's growing.
The kind of green
means it's stable.
The blue means it's decreasing.
It's interesting you
can see blue in cities
like San Francisco and New York.
Not necessarily because
they are shrinking,
but because of new
policies that are
trying to reduce
light pollution.
And street lights are
facing down rather than up.
But that big red blotch
over North Dakota
is the fracking oil
fields of North Dakota.
I think it's the
Bakken oil fields.
All right.
The European Parliament,
member of the parliament
and the Society for
Conservation Biology,
they came to us because
they wanted to map
where are the roadless
areas of the world.
Those last remaining places
that are untouched by humans.
Because those are the center
of biodiversity, for example.
And they had no way to do that.
So using Earth Engine, we
brought in the Google Maps Road
Data.
And we made a measurement
of all the areas
that were more than a certain
distance from the nearest road.
This is showing 1,000
meters, or one kilometer
from the nearest road.
But the organization wanted
to see 10 kilometers.
We just changed the code,
changed that constant, re-ran.
And you see how quickly
it reruns the results.
And there it is for
the whole world.
And they're using that now
as an instrument for policy,
trying to protect those areas.
All right.
So you've seen kind of
a whirlwind introduction
to geoscience, a little
bit of what you can do.
I just wanted to
end with what are
some of the amazing things
some of our partners
are doing beyond forest.
Forest was our first
use case, but now we're
really branching out
with these partners.
So David Lallemant at Stanford
is mapping earthquake hazard,
using Earth Engine.
This one I found
somewhat alarming.
So here we are, Bay Area.
You can bring in vector
data, as I mentioned.
Here's the San Andreas Fault.
He's modeled predicted
ground acceleration
in the event of a rupture
on San Andreas Fault of 7.8,
that matches the
1906 earthquake.
I asked him, I said hm,
I wonder where I live.
So we brought in two dots.
I don't know if
you can see them.
One down south is where I live.
The other dot is
near the Bay Bridge.
That's where we are right now.
You can see why you might care
about having this information.
Sea-level rise.
You may have seen in
the news that glaciers
are-- like the Antarctic
is calving these glaciers.
Sea-level's already
rising in certain places.
People need to know what
the risk is to their home,
to their livelihood.
And you can model that now.
With the digital elevation,
modeling sea-level
rise, where will
inundation happen.
This is being done with
the Australian government
and CRCSI.
Drought monitoring.
Very relevant here
in California.
So this is looking at anomalous
heat or wetness or dryness
in California for
the first two weeks
of December, last December.
And you can see what we all know
who live here, that California
is showing up bright red
because of the tremendous,
unprecedented drought that has
struck much of the American
West.
Now, a really important area.
It's a little bit more wonky.
It's called evapotranspiration.
But being able to model how
plants are taking up water.
How much water they're using.
So this is Nebraska over
the Ogallala Reservoir.
And we're modeling here--
this is Rick Allen's team,
University of
Nebraska and so on.
They're modeling where
plants are taking up water.
Now, this is important
for a lot of reasons,
like helping farmers
and food security.
But there's also,
we're discovering,
a lot of commercial interest
now in Earth Engine.
We developed Earth
Engine as this platform
for helping science,
helping humanity, protecting
the environment.
And that remains our huge focus.
But we're being approached
by, for example, Gallo Winery.
They manage 8 million acres
of vineyard in California.
They try to tell their
farmers, their growers,
how much irrigation to do.
They have eight people who
download Landsat data by hand
into a desktop.
And they run these algorithms
painfully on their desktop
that we have fully automated.
So they are now Trusted Testers,
Gallo Winery of Earth Engine.
And we're really excited
to see where that goes.
The last one I
wanted to show you
was emerging infectious disease,
or global public health.
This is one of the
more important ones.
We focused a lot on environment.
But it turns out
that you can predict,
by knowing environmental factors
like rainfall, temperature,
the greening of the
landscape that you
can see from the
satellite data-- we've
shown you some examples of that.
You can predict where
mosquitoes are going to hatch.
Where there's going to be
various types of disease
vectors, six or eight
weeks in advance.
And with that information,
you can mobilize the resources
much more effectively.
So UC San Francisco
is just starting
to use Earth Engine to
do this kind of analysis.
And the common theme that we're
hearing from these scientists
is they have the science.
They know how to do it.
But they've been limited to what
they can do on their desktop.
This is what Gallo
Winery told us also.
They want to scale.
They want to go big, right.
They want to go global.
And now Earth Engine
lets them do that.
These are some of our partners.
As you can see, they are
largely scientific institutions,
government institutions.
Because in fact, as
you've probably seen,
Earth Engine is a fairly
technical platform and API.
We're really honored
to be working
with some of these leading
scientists in the world.
We do have, again I said
it was an experimental API.
And maybe half of you are
scared off by what you've seen.
This is not a tool that lets
you send "yo" to someone.
[LAUGHTER]
Right?
It's kind of the other extreme.
So you can cut
yourself in this--
it's really massively powerful.
But you kind of got to
know what you're doing.
Or you could probably
get into trouble
and make a lot of stuff
that doesn't make any sense.
That said, we have a sign-up.
We have our website.
There's documentation.
There's tutorials,
introductory API tutorial.
And there's a
particular tutorial
on the Hansen global forest data
that we think is very useful.
So what did I want to say.
I think for a lot of you
guys, this technology
may be so out there that
it's not really relevant.
And that's fine.
That's great.
We have really hit a sweet spot
with the geoscience community.
What I'm excited about is seeing
if there is some middle ground.
Can we make remote sensing--
this type of earth observation
data analysis-- transformatively
or disruptively easier
than it's been before?
So you don't have to be
a Ph.D. in that field,
in order to be able to
come in with new ideas.
Contribute something new to this
community and to this space.
And maybe change
the world in a way
that no one has ever
anticipated before.
I know someone in this
room is going to do that.
I know people watching are
going to use Earth Engine
and they're going
to change the world.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
So we just-- I kind
of get excited.
I kind of go on too long.
But we do have a few
minutes for questions.
So please, come up to
the-- there's two mics.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm a fellow geodata
geek and developer.
And I work for a
commercial product
that allows you to move data
around, spatial data around.
And so I'm curious
about your ability
to export those
tiles that you've
computed with Earth Engine.
And I would be very
interested to hear more
about those capabilities.
REBECCA MOORE: That's
a great question.
A lot of our users
have already developed
some historic workflow
in some other tool chain.
But they see the
tremendous value
of using Earth Engine
for the data catalog,
for preprocessing, for producing
some of the data products
they need for their
other workflow.
So yes, you can
produce something
and then download it to Google
Drive, your own personal Google
Drive.
You can download it
over to Maps Engine.
But if you put it
in Drive, then you
can download it and do
whatever you want with it.
It's your data.
We have data liberation.
And this is a good
example of that.
Yes.
A lot of people are doing that.
Our goal is to make Earth
Engine so rich and so powerful
that fewer and fewer people
need to take the data away.
They can get the job
done in Earth Engine.
But whatever floats
your boat, that's fine.
Yes.
You're next.
AUDIENCE: Google has
announced their plans
to launch large
constellations of satellites
for communications.
But is Google intending to enter
the earth imaging arena also?
REBECCA MOORE: So I
think you're referring
to Skybox acquisition,
which we're
really excited about actually.
Because they are one of
those innovative, disruptive
new satellite companies.
Skybox collects
one meter imagery.
You can task their
constellation.
They just launched one so far.
They have plans to launch more.
I think there are a lot of
exciting integration points.
We can't speculate too
much, because it actually
hasn't closed, this deal.
But we can see a lot of really
exciting opportunities there.
Does that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
REBECCA MOORE: OK, yes.
AUDIENCE: I'm involved
with a project
to categorize road
segments by their width.
And it seems that this fits
with the set of tools you have.
Am I correct in thinking that?
REBECCA MOORE: If you have
access to the high-res data-- I
think the public data catalog
we have, Landsat for example.
Even if you pan-sharpen Landsat,
it's 15 meters per pixel.
And that probably
doesn't give you
the resolution you want
for mapping road width.
You're going to need a
higher resolution data set.
If we had Skybox data,
that's one meter per pixel.
They're commercial data sets.
Now if you have
that data already,
you could bring that into
your Maps Engine account.
And you can analyze
it in Earth Engine.
And yes, you could do that.
You could do that.
It would be interesting.
We'd love to try.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So two questions actually.
The first question
is that so you
did make mention of the
fact that you can come up
with irrigation
strategies, as far
as agriculture is concerned.
I'm just wondering,
can Google Earth Engine
be used for the
purpose of tracking
crop yields in rural areas?
Especially where there are
frequent food shortages.
REBECCA MOORE: Yeah, that's
an excellent question.
The answer is yes.
Some, at least two of
our science partners
that we know of are
already doing that.
A global crop yield estimation.
There are tremendous
applications
of that for food security,
as you're suggesting.
If you can bring in
information about drought,
rainfall patterns,
understanding something
about the nature of
the crops, and be
able to estimate the yield, it
has tremendous positive value.
And people are doing that, yes.
AUDIENCE: So the
second question I
had was pertinent to how often
is the imagery updated as
far as Google Earth
Engine is concerned?
So if you wanted to see what
your yield was in the last two
weeks or four weeks, is that
level of data available?
REBECCA MOORE: Yes.
I love to be able to say that.
Yes.
We have a feed from
US Geological Survey.
We're getting thousands of
images every day from them.
From all of their sensors.
All the Landsat satellites.
We get the data I think within
less than 24 hours of it
being collected.
So yes, there is
fresh data coming in,
available, in Earth Engine for
exactly that type of purpose.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
REBECCA MOORE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So I work a lot--
we do a lot of remote sensing
at my company.
REBECCA MOORE: Yay, there are
some remote sensing people
here.
AUDIENCE: And so I
gather that Earth Engine
is free to use for nonprofits
and for governments.
But what about commercial
licensing and rights
to resell derivative products?
REBECCA MOORE: Right, right.
So as I said, our birth
was public benefit,
advancing science,
nonprofit use.
We will continue to
really push on that.
But there are commercial
companies that are interested.
And we're actually
realizing that if you
want to change the world--
helping the business sector
do better management, for
example, of their supply chain.
So Nestle or Walmart or
Unilever or McDonald's
can verify that where
they're sourcing their palm
oil for their Girl
Scout cookies is not
resulting in illegal
deforestation.
That's a good thing.
So we're just starting
this year to work
with a handful of commercial
companies for free.
And letting them kick the
tires of Earth Engine.
But use it commercially.
The normal-- under our
Trusted Tester agreement--
normal license restriction is
you use it non-commercially.
But if you have a
commercial application
you want to experiment
with, you can contact us.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
REBECCA MOORE: But you have
to have a good use case.
Because our team is small.
We want to support
the people that we
think are going to do
really amazing things.
All right.
We have one minute left.
Who's going to-- yes.
AUDIENCE: So two questions.
The first one is I'm
curious about the plans
for improving the
support of vector data
within Google Earth Engine.
And the second is
whether support
exists for interannual
analysis, like you
would use for computational
model-building and predictive
efforts.
REBECCA MOORE: So I misled you.
We're actually a minute over.
What was the first question?
AUDIENCE: Plans for improving
the vector data supply.
REBECCA MOORE: Yes.
So today we integrate
with Google Fusion Tables.
And so knock yourself out.
We have a whole suite of vector
operations on Google Fusion
Tables.
We're also integrating with
Maps Engine, Google Maps Engine
vector tables.
That should be
coming out this year.
So we should have pretty rich
support for different vector
backends from Earth Engine.
But today you can
use Fusion Tables.
Interannual analysis,
yes you could do that.
But why don't we talk
offline so I understand
more specifically what
you're trying to do.
All right you guys,
thank you very much.
Go change the world.
[APPLAUSE]